hey guys so I'm not sure if you've seen
But Stephen Crowder made a video about
an offer he received from the daily wire
he criticized DW for supporting big Tech
on January 17th Jeremy boring the CEO of
DW made a response video and then on
January 18th Stephen posted another
video where he played part of a
conversation with Jeremy that he had
recorded on the phone without Jeremy
knowing the whole thing's crazy given
dad is signed with DW I thought I'd
comment a bit about the contract as I
run my dad's brand and help negotiate
the contract the dad signed as well as
tell you what working with DW has been
like also I like Stephen Crowder I think
he's extremely entertaining I've watched
him comment on the election it's funny
my guess is the point of this whole
thing must be to launch something that
would be considered in competition with
DW his own platform that's my guess I
have no idea if that's true and that
would be fine the more the merrier there
should be more conservative platforms
out there but that's no reason to tear
each other down and create drama in my
opinion I thought I should address his
insinuation though that people working
at DW are locked into contracts they
don't like taking advantage of and
forced to do whatever DW says because
that makes my dad look naive and
incompetent of which he is neither so I
like Stephen again but I think things
need explaining on our end anyway if
you're an artist or an Entertainer or in
my dad's case intellectual internet dad
and you get a contract you read it
thoroughly and you negotiate until you
either love it or if you can't agree you
go your separate ways negotiate like a
shark it's not the contract that you
don't have to sign that's an issue it's
how well you can negotiate if it locks
you in for years you better know what
you're getting into read it think
negotiate use lawyers and make a
decision they're definitely naive people
who don't understand contracts and don't
pay enough attention are too young or
are advised badly and they sign up and
then say they're a musician they end up
losing 50 maybe 70 percent of their
income for decades fortunately we're not
naive and we've negotiated business
deals before I'd also like to address
the fact that Dad retweeted Steven's
video to add to the drama because Steven
sent it around and dad does that to
support Stephen because we like it but
when dad found out what the video was he
deleted the Tweet DW actually asked him
not to delete it because they said it
would look like they had asked him to
delete it but at that point he'd already
deleted it so that's the story of the
Tweet anyway let me explain a bit about
the deal my dad signed when we received
an offer from DW to produce dad's
podcast
Etc it was an all-encompassing offer
where DW would take over production of
the podcast and run and grow social
media channels and monetize YouTube and
dad would be paid a large amount of
money for that in a multi-year deal it
seems pretty similar to the one Steven
was offered when you've built something
yourself and I started the social media
channels between like 2014 and 2017. oh
and dad started YouTube like decades ago
and Twitter whenever that started when
you've built something yourself it's
pretty intense to sign it over to
someone are you going to have the
freedom to do what you want are people
going to think you're a sellout the
contract was intense they offered a lot
lot of money it was basically a 360 deal
but they get all the revenue from
monetizing the podcast and other content
and dad would get a fee they also wanted
the podcast initially behind their
paywall anyway we were doing pretty fine
by ourselves we had a small team that
was running the podcast we have online
products that dad started decades ago
it's not like we hadn't managed to
monetize social media in the last three
five years the online products are from
way before Dad got famous we had a few
upcoming podcast deals that looked
really good so things were good dad was
feeling better dad's still feeling very
good mom's healthy and we definitely
didn't need to sign the deal we say no
to offers all the time I love saying no
it used to be hard but I love saying no
now and I believe DW and our team went
back and forth over the contract for
five months the last three months we
changed things in it every day we had
lawyers look over it dad's agent my
husband and I basically have that
multi-page it's like a 15-page contract
memorized word for word if DW is going
to run the social media channels we grew
and his podcast and YouTube channel
we're going to make sure this is
something we really wanted we wanted to
make sure we could pursue what we wanted
now and in the future start new projects
if we wanted talk about whatever dad
wants tour write books like I said he
has his online products like
self-authoring and understand myself and
we wanted to make sure we could continue
to advertise those and collect that
Revenue ourselves those are separate
companies my brother has essay a writing
tool so we wanted to make sure it's like
partly owned by Dad we wanted to make
sure he could work on that and advertise
and talk about that and we wanted to
make sure we could build Peterson
Academy because an online university is
something dad has wanted to work on for
years we'd already started that project
so it was a complicated negotiation we
negotiated like crazy over the contract
it was like a movie level of intense it
was fun but it was intense we weren't
giving them anything we weren't more
than happy to give them and they were
doing the same to us we ended up with a
contract that kept dad's podcast on
YouTube for free which was insane that
that was allowed I think given the
amount of money that was on the table
left out his other projects left out his
books left out touring and gave him the
freedom to pursue what he wants in the
future and gave him access to their
production team advertising budget and
audience on DW plus and more they
offered dad production value and a level
of support we couldn't have and didn't
do ourselves like their team is huge
they have way more money than us the
reason that his podcast looks better now
is because they literally fly people out
to film dad's guests that's crazy they
fly a crew to film his guess and he
records twice a week they fly around
with Dad so he doesn't have to set up
Zoom podcasts anymore and he has all
these like fancy camera angles they do
everything he just walks in and Records
now he can record from anywhere so he's
not even forced to like be in a studio
they go three hours away from his house
to film the podcast as cottage so it's
convenient for him they were on tour all
over Europe Australia it's crazy he
wanted to film some documentaries and
they have a team ready to go to make
whatever documentaries he wants so now
he has one on the Bible Museum he's
recorded two more they took over filming
for his tour so before DW we were
filming his shows on tour to have the
footage but it was in a pretty simple
way you can set it up with the venue you
can get pretty nice footage depending on
the venue but you can't get the type of
footage GW is getting with the budget
they have and the budget we had for
filming so now all of my dad's lectures
are filmed professionally like kind of
like Netflix style which makes everyone
in my family happy because he's not
going to be around forever I want that
footage for like memory's sake or
whatever so we get that back after the
deal's over and while the deal's on the
tour's on DW plus they filmed an exodus
Roundtable discussion that Dad came up
with that took two weeks to film a
million dollars producing it we couldn't
have done that they had a large group of
people helping with him with social
media we had one person at the moment
I'm virtually certain they're not
recouping what they're paying dad to be
on their platform and spending on
production he's also still free on
YouTube there's just extra content
basically that's behind their paywall
that we wouldn't have been making anyway
so that's kind of just extra and a lot
of it is given to us after the contract
ends at least for us this was an
absurdly good deal gave us all the
freedom we wanted and supportive a
massive team otherwise we would have
just kept doing what we were doing which
was working well but this deal has
helped him take some well it's helped me
take some work off my plate and it's
exposed them to more people their budget
for advertising is in the millions
they're spending as much as they're
paying my dad just to produce his
content the team's quite enjoyable to
work with and if we want to remove
things off of social media or talk about
whatever we can do whatever they
basically just helped us boost
production gave us an opportunity to
pursue projects with a Hollywood level
team and paid us a ton of money and I I
believe that that's actually what
happened the original contract didn't
start that way but that's normal for a
contract for a business contract that's
why it's called a business negotiation
even if you're trying to buy a house
you're like what's the house worth okay
uh offer less right that's just how you
negotiate business it's a lot of money
that they were offering so everyone on
both sides was careful about what the
deal was anyway I think conservatives
should be working together to fight
common enemies the woke crowd that's
taking over the world destroying Canada
trying to stop us from eating meat
confusing our kids fighting capitalism
freaking people out about the climate
keeping people scared and indoors
burning down areas and cities destroying
California and other liberal cities
limiting freedom of speech forcing
vaccines on people that needs to be
fought tooth and nail and fighting
amongst each other is not a good way to
go about that we have bigger problems
out there so our experience with DW is
that they're definitely sharks they know
business they know social media
production products content and they
know how to negotiate luckily so do we
which is why it's been a great
partnership so far and obviously I am
not one of the DW crew so this is all
coming from someone who's like attached
to it but pretty outside of it it's not
like Jeremy's calling me up being like
Michaela you're not part of it you do it
you look good that wasn't happening I'm
still waiting for my million dollar deal
millions of dollars deal
but nothing yet so I hope that clarifies
things for people we'll see what happens